on commence ce journal par la série
dommage à l'Ukraine rendu à travers le
monde en ce jour d'anniversaire de
l'invasion russe à l'île un
rassemblement a été organisé sur le pont
de carquive rebaptisé en soutien à la
ville jumelles de Lille les couleurs de
l'Ukraine aussi mise à l'honneur voyez à
Londres sur des routes repeintes à
Bruxelles sur le bâtiment de la
Commission européenne ou encore à Sydney
ou l'opéra séparé de jaune et de bleu il
est le visage de l'Ukraine qui résiste
et en ce jour c'est lui qui s'avance le
président soldat devant ses troupes le
drapeau jaune et bleu étendard d'une
nation attaquée
je veux dire à vous qui combattez et à
vous qui vivez en Ukraine
à quel point je suis fier de vous nous
sommes tous chers
Coluche transformé en de Gaulle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quand j'ai compris ce système de dire on
peut oser un coup de main parce que ça
je l'explique vraiment dans le livre
parce que ça c'est culturel dans notre
société pourquoi demander un coup de
main on lui commande des honneurs
maintenant
qui me dit on manque de bras il
m'appelle je dise pas la peine mais
c'est pour vous la fassiez pas comme ça
c'est fait merci on a fait un beau
mélange des genres là ce soir vous voir
ils arrivent Lina à côté de Philippe
Croizon et de Michaël Youn surtout enfin
c'est ce mélange
largement vous connaissez ce jeune homme
c'est pas moi
c'est pas moi non plus
vous avez fait preuve d'autodérision
c'est génial vous dites je me suis pas
fait d'entorse à la cheville depuis 1994
vous dites la crème pour les mains ça
marche pas non il y a que génératrice
vous dites qu'il y a un follower qui a
dit les bons moments de 2020 se comptent
sur les doigts de Philippe Croizon voilà
c'est pas mal bah oui et l'humour
Poutine c'est un tsar sanglant qui se
prend les pieds dans le tapis et qui ne
sait pas comment s'en sortir
sanglant combien de mots aujourd'hui on
a deux propagandes qui s'affront donc il
faut qu'on soit très méfiant américain
mais il y a une propagande américaine
bien sûr qu'elle propagande américaine
alors le problème c'est que quelquefois
disent des choses vraies mais moi je
l'ai vécu de mes yeux vu sur la faire en
Irak où j'ai vu comme une poète et
George Bush dans un dîner à l'Élysée
nous certifier qu'il y avait des armes
destruction massives et ils mettaient
toute leur énergie et on est on finit
c'est presque par les coins l'Ukraine
effrayant de ces images de retrouvailles
qui circulent abondamment sur les
réseaux sociaux
l'armée les diffusent aussi bien
volontiers dans sa communication soignée
le pays pleure avec cette grand-mère qui
chancelle au retour de son petit-fils
adoré
et admire unanimement ces soldats pour
leur courage et leur sens de sacrifice
donc j'ai vu ce grand mensonge américain
j'en suis toujours marqué mais c'est bon
je n'en sais rien je n'en sais rien ce
que je veux dire c'est que je l'ai vécu
Tik Tok banni de la Commission
européenne à Bruxelles les salariés
doivent supprimer l'application chinoise
de leur téléphone professionnel et
personnelle demande faite hier par mail
en raison de la menace en cybersécurité
que représente le réseau social chinois
on le sait Tic-Toc peut consulter
certaines données personnelles de ses
utilisateurs le risque d'espionnage a
déjà poussé les États-Unis à agir là-bas
la pli est interdite sur les appareils
des fonctionnaires
Tik Tok aux États-Unis a été utilisé
pour remonter jusqu'au source de
certains journalistes qui travaillaient
sur sur l'entreprise via la
géolocalisation sur le téléphone des
journalistes en question ce qu'on ne
sait pas justement c'est dans quelle
mesure ces données transit de manière
régulière
Brad Pitt
[Applaudissements]
ma vie a changé pour toujours en ce jour
de 94 où j'ai pris un café avec David
Fincher et voilà Brad il est en France
en ce moment dispose si vous avez un pot
de départ ou un anniversaire surprise
appelez Brad merci pour ces 5 années de
bonheur merci aussi d'être là au
quotidien pour moi et les
téléspectateurs aussi je pense ont envie
de te remercier pour 30 ans 30 ans que
de bonheur de de rire et d'humanité et
d'argent aussi
je remplis la cagnotte pour ma fille
elle est où votre fille elle est là-bas
et comment elle s'appelle votre fille
[Applaudissements]
prénom ça aussi
ça monte alors
[Musique]
c'est votre vrai nom c'est vrai Samantha
love contrôle
[Applaudissements]
vous allez quand même pas oser couper
une femme noire en plein discours mais
si c'est possible donc je vais aller
très vite est-ce qu'on en a trop fait
tout simplement est-ce qu'on est devenu
fou avec
merci la première chose que je voudrais
dire c'est commencer par la phrase de
gros chômage je n'accepterai jamais de
faire partie d'un club qui m'accepterait
comme membre qu'est-ce que je suis en
train de faire je suis en train de
devenir moi-même commenter quelque chose
dont je récuse qu'il soit commenté 24
heures sur 24 voilà le paradoxe dans
lequel vous mettez ma chaleur lequel des
sets World Disney aurait pu travailler
pour l'éducation nationale
prof et puis
je me suis pris en pleine poire comme
tout le monde les gens étaient fous
Simone il s'évanouissait dans
le haut Simone Veil c'est c'est la bière
quoi
en juif
il y a déjà eu quatre victimes faudrait
pas qu'il y en a une cinquième j'ai
l'impression simplement j'ai pas il
attendra jamais assez jour il s'aime
trop pour ça oh
de dire ça ça voudrait dire que tu
l'espère bien
et puisqu'on dit que le silence et la
musique de l'âme et ben on va s'arrêter
là pour ce soir